recently there's been like a big trend
of like as I said earlier like over
sexualized seriously we've got a shoe
mats and a harem yeah my [ __ ] god how
they gonna handle how are they gonna
handle that because there is
legitimately a sex scene every like I'm
not even kidding so III don't know
anything about this monger sir wait what
is it called again it's called shoe
mutts on a hair or world's and Harold
and harem and basically the the overall
plot I'm over simplifying this but
basically it's a hemorrhoid blog
humanity has gone to [ __ ] where there is
a disease that is killing all males it's
affecting males so basically now you can
tell males now are becoming like a
commodity they're basically being
treated like males that have like to
survive this disease yeah basically like
treated as like national let me guess
right first of all the difference
between this and hentai right is that if
it was a hentai it being ugly bastard
but like the dynamic see this is where a
difference from a hint either is that
our main character has like this girl
that he's been thinking about his whole
life yeah and basically like doesn't
want to just go around and like yes yeah
sex everyone in order to save he met
he'd rather keep his like purity for the
goal that he leaves been thingy crazy
yeah so it's about it's about waiting
for the right person it's basically blue
ball feed the market because everyone
else all five other guys having a
[ __ ] great time they're [ __ ] you
different chicks every [ __ ] yeah
they're pretty much they're pretty much
like what hinto protagonist should be